you are watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video I
thought I might just do a quick video on
the topic of smartphones with a bit of a
wider perspective here it's just really
me conveying some of the thoughts I've
been having over the past couple of days
so lately I've just been doing a bit of
reading up on Mobile World Congress you
know watching some video isn't that kind
of thing and I quickly realize that
there are two big stars this year
Samsung and LG I also noticed that
Samsung was kind of playing it safe
maybe because they have too much to lose
if they get things wrong but regardless
they kind of go in the Apple way that is
iteration and refinement rather than an
innovative overhaul while the s7 seems
to be better than the s6 in every way
especially in the battery and camera
department I'm not too keen on that
philosophy all in all it really doesn't
matter because Samsung will sell more
phones because they still have that
consumer momentum that's not the main
point of this video the main point of
this video and what I'm trying to get at
is LG LG on the other hand is doing what
Samsung used to do in earnest a few
years ago that is innovate try some
crazy ideas and see what works that's
actually how the Galaxy Note line came
about with the g5 LG have truly gone for
the innovation route what do I mean by
this basically the company has released
a modular phone this means a user can
quickly switch out parts to create
different functionalities depending on
the users needs in terms of modules so
far there's a camera mount with an
extended battery with physical buttons
for the shutter zoom and video recording
and also an audio add-on for hi-fi
listening even though I'm not a fan of
how this phone looks from the back I
still think this idea is pretty cool and
probably the best challenge to Samsung's
Android dominance
since the HTC One m7 so this is
especially interesting to me because
earlier last year I did a video
predicting what the future of the
smartphone could be in that video under
the function section
I said modular phone designs will start
to leak into the mainstream if the price
of handsets stayed elevated
with LG's release it looks like this is
already starting to happen that being
said the g5 is just the first generation
product of the modular idea and my guess
would be that the add-ons would probably
be pretty expensive and wouldn't offer
enough functionality to be worth it for
some people but still I think this is
the start of something modular designs
that make a whole lot of sense it may
just be a matter of time before we get
to the project ara stage of swapping out
cameras CPUs RAM and various other
integrated components effortlessly
instead of going out and buying an
entirely new handset each and every time
so in conclusion with phones like the LG
g5 and even the next bit Robin a phone
which primarily relies on cloud storage
it's good to see this kind of thing as
we have to send a bit of a revolving
door of ideas in the smartphone industry
over the past few years you know a
little spark is needed every now and
again so a modular phones here with LG
being the first major manufacturer to
put one of these out to the market and
also the fairphone to being the first
ever modular phone the answer is yes
modular phones are here but they've just
got their toes in the door we'll have to
watch the space closely and see how this
all plays out hopefully more
manufacturers take modular designs
onboard maybe even just as an optional
extra on a particular model so yeah that
was just a quick video with a few of my
thoughts I just thought I'd like to
share them with you as a side point I
was going to do a video on the ringing
bells freedom to 5-1 its a four-dollar
smartphone set to be released in India
in a few months I say I was going to do
a video on that because when I
researched a little deeper it actually
looks like a scam the parts alone would
cost way more than $4 and then I thought
yeah that's okay as long as there's a
subsidy from an entity such as the
Indian government themselves which I
thought was the case but up the phone's
launch it was revealed that there was no
such subsidy so the price point at $4 is
seemingly impossible moreover they don't
even have a factory yet and the worst
thing is that
at the phones launch there were some
wite-out near the speaker grille
covering a different branded phone so
that means at the launch the company
just bought a whole bunch of phones and
put wite-out over the name and called it
their own so it fails to weigh all of
this up it seems 80% likely that the
four dollar phone is too good to be true
I could be wrong but I don't think it's
worth making a full video on it if it's
most likely going to be a scam but
anyway that's enough for me let me know
your thoughts on modular phones this has
been - gogo you've been watching cold
fusion give this video a thumbs up if
you liked it definitely subscribe if
you're new go around and check out some
previous videos in this channel there's
a whole bunch of interesting stuff for
you and I'll catch you again soon for
the next video cheers guys have a good
one Ian are you thinking
ah